in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to an episode of the
genius brain podcast quarantine style in
the house yeah we're doing this still in
the home right now
the genius brain podcast will be moving
to a new office because the office that
I'm using right now kind of sucks ass
they closed down because the Cobra
situation and we have my co-host for the
meantime mati song everybody ready les
my fiance of now not even a year but my
girlfriend for for before fiance about
mm-hm
we I proposed to her in Japan mmm next
to the Kamala River oh you remember the
river name of course I proposed there
that's right so going to the max baby I
proposed to her next to the kamigamo
River if you guys don't know what the
camel gone River or as other people call
it the Kama River I'm not sure that's
true okay thank God it was a river that
she commuted next to while she was in
Kyoto so when we went to Japan we it was
for a business trip and I actually paid
for a ticket because I didn't want her
to suspect anything
I had no idea damn straight you want to
hear the funniest story - what so on the
way so when I was proposing to her I
didn't really plan out where to propose
to her because I didn't know her I
didn't want to prod with too many
questions about her relationship with
Kyoto or Japan because if I did it would
give it away he said why is he asking so
many questions I know right so I was
like okay when I'm there I have to
figure it out as we go as you start to
say things and then I'm like okay so
usually say things as we go I'm like oh
I used to do this over here or if you go
over there this is what I used to do and
then you were like there's this river I
used to communit I'm and it's like right
over there when we're gonna kill it I
was like boom I got it so I had to
figure out a time that we could go but
because our sleeping schedule was so
different over there we wake up at 4:00
a.m. either way so I was like okay well
we can get there before everybody else
does that we can get there at sunrise
and
top of that this was like very lucky for
us is that throughout the whole week it
was supposed to be rainy but for some
reason that those couple days when we're
in Kyoto
it was sunny it was beautiful jinx baby
yeah but it was it was super beautiful
and if I do say so myself
but that's not the funny part the
[ __ ] funny part was when we were
about to propose right and this is
during the time I brother had a
girlfriend this woman says as I have the
ring on me she goes you be really funny
if your brother proposed
propose bowls proposed to his girlfriend
before you proposed to me that's so
pissed and in my mind I was like you
better shut the hell up with me you
don't know what you don't know shoot
hey prior to that okay here's the story
so we were talking about getting engaged
for a really long time and he's been
talking about for about a year and I'm
like okay now it needs to get all of a
serious we've been dating for four years
when is this gonna happen and I looked
and I was like so when is it gonna
happen he looked at me and asked oh I
gotta do it and I'm like what little did
she know we actually planned that Japan
trip way like six seven months in
advance and I already decided that I was
going to do it there really you over
here just grilling me and I'm like I'll
give you the credit it was so annoying
because I already knew where I wanted to
do it but she was grilling me so much
for like six seven months it was pissing
me off and so I keep this up I'm not
gonna do it I'm gonna drown you in the
river instead whatever I have to give
you a deadline I didn't need no deadline
dude you know what I was gonna propose
to you in the first three years we were
together but you wasn't ready for all
this oh no I was not ready indeed and I
know you so I need to give you a
deadline I need to give you a little
poke here and there I love you I already
knew when I was ahead overall let's say
that the proposal was fabulous you want
to tell me what the original tell you
the what the original proposal was yeah
so this was the original proposal you
would hate I didn't know well you never
told me about you either what I loved it
or you would have hated it so before I
decided I was gonna do it I was this
gonna be a joke
I was going to be a huge joke so
this was the original proposal so
because so if you guys don't already
know Muriel is a huge Disney fan huge
Disney fan like you love Disney like
when I first met her I did not like the
first frozen and the first frozen is a
film that changed her life apparently
like it's dead it was a life-changing
experience because like I'm a huge
Disney fan was at that time Disney
didn't really released uh you know great
movies back then because they were
transferring from 2d to 3d like Toy
Story the hell's back sorry different
yeah and I mean they had tangled but
that was like about it and so I wasn't
really into Disney but then when I
watched it with no expectation I just
heard that it was great so I was like
okay my mom wanted to go watch I was
like okay let's go in came out crying
and had like this let's hold revolution
of like revelation I mean revelation
[Laughter]
revolution basically this epiphany of my
life because I long story short I was a
I was a pretty low point in that light
at that time this was before you met me
this was performing yeah yeah so frozen
came up before you met me and then I
watched frozen with you for my first
time yes that's right I wasn't in
theaters it was in my living room yes
yeah was it it was in my living room in
k-town hmm we didn't watching the
theaters together okay we watched it and
we were we were in the living room on
that gray couch I'm watching it and I
did not like it and then you made me
stop watching it yeah you said I
couldn't watch the movie anymore so I
didn't finish the film
really yeah then we watched again later
and I finished it we had that
conversation you're like I don't like
I'm like what yeah you said you're not
allowed to watch this film editor today
I was so sensitive about it because it
changed my life
I mean frozen is the reason how I got
into Disney oh it was the first it was
like the first start of how I changed my
perspective my life and got into Disney
what do you mean
basically it gave me motivation
inspirations I was just so curious I
looked up and like did all these random
stuff and basically a
me a reason to move forward because I
thought what was it about the film
though the film well first I was very
fascinated by the technology of it just
how realistic those fabrics were and at
that time I don't know anything about
animation I just remember how amazing
the technology was it's just like I
could almost feel that dress I could
almost sense how soft it would be if I
touched it and the animation was great I
think this I think the story was amazing
I felt like I was at that time it's
interesting because I at that time it
from other person's point of view they
probably thought O'Mara's just like on
a-- but for me at that time during that
phase I felt like I was Elsa and what do
you mean just like on explain in terms
of my personality is very bubbly and I'm
very like you know the Genki girl the
the the positive vibe think it means
happy Genki means happy yeah and a lot
of people told me in like Oh Anna
reminds me of you I know reminds me of
you whatever but at that time I was in a
very low phase and a low point in my
life and I felt like I was like I was
like Elsa where I couldn't figure out
how to open the doors basically like I
feel like I was closed in and I didn't
know how to get out of it mmm I was
struggling about then and just it's just
that emotion connected so well with Elsa
at that time and I think I was just it
gave me a reason to be interested in
something because at that time it was I
had basically long story short again I
don't want to go into this side but I
had an accident in Taiwan and had to
come back and I had to rest for a really
long time and that was pretty depressing
because I couldn't do much in terms of
like you know walking around or like I
had to stay in bed for about a year and
it was a struggle for me to get back up
physically and emotionally and my mom
helped me a lot and that kind of sense
where she would take me out and she
wanted to go watch frozen and that was
like a turning point for me oh okay it's
so weird that I thought a CG animated
film did that you know and and I was
kind of giggling before
she was like I was looking at the dress
and I could almost I could feel it and
the reason why I know this to be true
how much she likes the the technological
side of CG animation
she used to piss me off when we watch
movies and we're trying to watch
something right and as I'm she knows I
hate this like when I'm watching the
film being spoken to if it's like a film
like TV shows whatever but like this is
this is the jungle book that we're
watching right literally this is so
funny because she said this to me where
she goes you know what I hate I hate it
when people talking movies she my
friends Holly talks so much and it
annoys me so much and I'm like cool you
and I we're the same we don't like and
when people talk to us in films right
when the movie starts do you see the CG
animation in this film let me tell you
something so when they do this I looked
at I was like what the [ __ ] they weren't
doing anything they weren't talking so I
was just admiring just started to break
down the technological investments think
about it I'm the less person the less
talking person I could only know my
friend I would strangle them yeah you
know who agent ray hates of the most I
don't I would even go to theirs with ray
cuz oh he didn't want to deal with
anybody you watch this all by himself
yeah all he does is watch it films by
himself because he can't stand when
people talk at Talking films and he
watches it like late at night yeah
doesn't want anybody to be in there yeah
so I mean oh yeah but anyways the
original proposal oh just a background
for her for her Disney loved the
original proposal was I was I had a
makeup VFX artist friend of mine and I
was going to recreate Beauty and the
Beast and you were going to come into
the house right and I was going to have
like a makeshift thing where the outside
and the inside looks like a castle and
when you come in it's good it was
literally gonna be set up where somebody
grabs you and then that you know in that
back area that was the podcast room it
was gonna be set up as a cage and you're
gonna be thrown in that cage and inside
that cage was gonna be your father not
your actual dead but an actor that plays
your dad Frank I did you were gonna have
to trade places with him
because up by the VFX artists the makeup
artist was gonna put my face as a beast
that is horrifying that you would have
to trade places with your dad uh-huh
right I think you were kind of like I
was gonna get the actor to kind of nudge
you towards the lines cuz you'll figure
out easy that this is actually beauty of
the beast uh-huh because you'll see my
face uh-huh
and then I was gonna record everything
and then after that I was gonna take
have somebody dress up as you know the
the dresser oh yeah yeah it's gonna be
in my room and we're gonna decorate it
out as an Beauty and the Beast stuff
well I take it to the room and then she
was gonna make you dress up for dinner
and then I was gonna scream whether you
like to come dinner and you're gonna say
no because you know the law I was gonna
scream at you then starve and then I go
cry on the bed yeah it was gonna be this
whole funny ordeal but then I kind of
like but it's a lot of work it was gonna
cost a lot of money that's why just the
the makeup alone was gonna be like three
men so like that yeah when you're a
millionaire let's do that what I
calculated how much it was almost like
this is gonna cost more than the ring
and the trip put together just because I
wanted to laugh the most expensive joke
ever it was gonna be like you're like
close like 12 like no it was a lot yeah
it would have been a great video it
would have but I think the video would
have be support for my entertainment
yeah I don't know if I would have liked
that as a proposal it would have been
hilarious but the original one was a
scary you [ __ ] this and make it Disney
themed and then I was advised not to do
it you know viced you everybody okay
great everybody thank you so much yeah
that's what the original proposal was
because if you ask me how are you gonna
ask me that noise
what am I good I don't know how are you
gonna ask me what how were you gonna
propose at the end
well after I get you upstairs the and
star thing right I was gonna dress up
and then downstairs in the living room
area was gonna be put up as like a ball
area we would dance and everything else
so it'll be like a mini it would be a
mini version of the film just very sped
up that's a lot of work it is it was one
of those things that it was I was trying
to be really creative with thought
that'd be fun maybe really really funny
that would be that's a lot of work it is
a lot of work and just that makeup alone
will be ridiculous and it's a very long
process and how would you change from oh
would you be Beast the whole time yes it
would've been funny a really fat Beast
yeah you were pretty skinny no I was
thin by that yeah yeah but that was the
original plan I'm so glad that didn't
happen that was quite entertaining to
hear but co geek Betty it was only up to
there it would have been the hurry
yeah but anyways guys you guys were very
interested in this talking about this
show called terrace house I love terrace
house to the [ __ ] max daisuki desk it
is okay so just to give you as a
background if you guys don't know
already the last time we talked about
terra's honest people liked it so
terraced house is a reality TV show
based in Japan they go to different
parts of Japan sometimes there was one
in Kyoto there was one in Tokyo they
went to Tokyo again it wasn't it was it
was somewhere else it was like in the
country so yeah some countryside which
is really beautiful by the way I love
that one there they went to Hawaii I
said to my best friend
you scared that's my best friend right
there dude I love that guy you know one
of my photos that I posted on my
Instagram our first date photo they said
that you were going to be scared
that's cute guy yes he's pretty
good-looking guy yes a compliment he's a
little [ __ ] that's all yes yeah but
yeah so in this new season it's so
interesting because there's a character
that I really really enjoy on the show
his name is number one first of all she
loves this guy in every every [ __ ]
woman on this show if you guys watch
this latest season they love this guy he
left later on but his name is deal oh he
is this basketball player yeah very
handsome this is part three that we're
talking about prior tonight was part two
were puppet but they left and I'm really
sad oh wait was this Italian among the
artists Pepa left him beginning of part
three actually there are many a part
that he was there for the first episode
part 3 where he finally saw his his
first publish yeah
pepé is a really cool dude he's an
italian manga artist that moved to japan
he was a I forgot what inspired him
exactly but he came here to become a
manga artist and so his goal in the
house was to make sure that that dream
came true yeah and it finally did and
when it did is was it was his time to
leave oh yeah and that's it was it was
interesting because the first time he
ever saw his manga get published he went
to a convenience store and oh my god
this woman was crying her eyes out cut
it was such a great moment where he was
just celebrating on his own he looked at
it read it looked through all the pages
realizing that it's published it's out
there and nobody was around him he
didn't celebrate it with you know
friends or whatever he just looked at it
enjoyed in like absorb that moment and
it was silent and I was just tearing up
because you could see how they're
tearing up right now as you're thinking
about how hard you worked Muriel is a
very sensitive soul this is one of my
funniest stories that she's ever done so
just to go back on the topic of us
watching these but she so you guys
remember you know Paul Walker rest in
peace he passed with it so we went to go
watch Fast and Furious it was the last
film that he was in where they had to
put him in CG towards the end this woman
is so ridiculous we're watching the film
and there's that part where goes he's
been a long day without you my friend
you know that that song and then Paul
Walker is in his car he looks over at
Dom Toretto they kind of smile as a CG
version of himself and the heat Rudy's
all you mean Dom Toretto
his Vin Diesel as these actor names I
was like okay and then so he desperately
miss my bed but as he's driving off they
kind of look at each other and that song
comes on and I see Mariel bawling her
eyes out as if she was at a Funeral like
you
we're crying nobody like I understand
the tears part right but the amount that
you were crying was unreal and I'm the
best at okay I grew up watching fast in
there furious I watched most of the
sequels so I'm invested in this so did I
but the way you have no emotion I know I
was a very emotional part but it's not
the fact that you cried it was how much
you were crying that threw me off the
sock did it help I've been the one she
responded to was the most ridiculous
thing I've ever heard I go what like in
the theater she goes it's my final
goodbye it's my final goodbye invested
in these okay when I watch it I imagine
myself being in that moment in that
story that's why when it when pepper was
looking at and nothing was happening it
was the grandma that was there that
beiping sent it over the edge it did
it's it I was getting very emotional
when I was just like man I'm so proud of
you I don't even know you
Pepa but I know that you were very
passionate you work really hard for it
and then you achieved you composed what
oh my god I lost the word yeah either
way she was very very emotional at that
scene he was actually one of my favorite
characters and the reason why is like he
has a quality that I really really enjoy
so and what I mean by that is that I
think like growing up for for me anyways
people were categorized in in certain
things and you couldn't break out of it
like for example if you were a jock you
were a jock and and what came along with
jock was that you were a muscle meathead
that was that would had a very low IQ
that's just what you were right in high
school I think a lot of people do that
if you're if you're a geek you're a nerd
you're the guy that's a point Dexter he
gets good grades he's never gonna get a
girlfriend he's a dweeb whatever right
and then what we're finding out now
specifically because of like social
media and people being able to show on
and they're finding that there's a
community outside of this small little
box that people put you in that you can
be multiple things right you can be a
dweeb that's charismatic this
charismatic that has confidence and
that's what Pepe is Pepe is a [ __ ]
dweeb but in the
best way possible like he's nerdy he
likes his little cartoon his Bond guys
and he's kind of like he's like freakin
Italian a [ __ ] hyper Italian yeah he's a
shy Italian yes like he's a little bit
more reserved than like the typical like
much he's mo Talia man that you know
that you kind of picture with like a
rose in his mouth making pasta every day
yeah what he didn't make pasta almost
every I know and it looks so good yeah
but he kind of like categorizes what I
like about somebody is that you can be
very cool you can be very charismatic
and confident even though categorically
people think you're very dweeby because
dweeb is not an insult it's just kind of
like it is what you are like you're a
dweeb like you're a geek maybe a geek or
nerd or whatever what doesn't mean that
you can't be cool yeah and that's what I
really liked about him because he kind
of he doesn't he has no shame in he's
very true to himself yes he doesn't
perform like you know when he likes a
girl he he shows who he is yeah he's a
good-looking guy he's like he's not
muscular or anything like that
he's just he has his charisma about him
his confidence he's very goal-oriented
very adorable very passionate he's I
think he has a good sense of humor very
great sense yeah very positive he's very
optimistic you know it's just you see
the bright side of him and I think
that's very attractive and so like and
it's very refreshing for me to see
because I see or I used to see a lot of
people these are the people that I
distance myself from now it's like
especially like in social media you know
some of these youtubers like when they
were younger or let me just use tubers
like people who are actors or whatever
for some reason this is weird habit when
people come into this city they stop
being who they were before because they
come into a new city and they try to
create a new identity but it's like let
me tell you something if you were a
dweeb since you were [ __ ] the one
years old like I was your dweeb all the
way through and through it seeps out of
your skin problem is now is like what I
hate is the it doesn't have to be a
dweeb or a nerd it could be like a thug
or whatever you are who you are just own
it and when you try not be when you try
to be something that you're not it's so
uncomfortable looking at you and being
around you is this
are you talking about people who are
adults these are adults okay yeah
because I'm thinking like well like
college people go to college see like
college fine find themselves but they
don't know who they are yeah so they
like put up a face on it you know they
try to become a whole different person
and I think that's a great face to
explore who you are but then after you
pass her college face like I think
that's when you should be really true to
yourself or try try to figure it out and
it's sad because it's not just a college
thing I thought that in colleges that's
where it would end because it was very
prevalent in college and I would see
that in a lot of people for example
there was this dude that I met in
college I talked about it before with
Joe his name was Andy and lost he's a
Chinese dude I can't remember him deal
and I want to say Andy there was one
there was a guy named Andrew Jiang and
there was another dude named Andy god
it's blanking right now but if I think
about it I'll remember his name but long
story short if people haven't heard this
on the previous podcast with Joe and he
was one of those guys that was clearly
like a geek in the worst way possible
not a very cool geek or a nerd right
it's like I had this other fight in his
name was Tony mm-hmm Tony I love this
guy to death he was like a magnet school
kid mm-hmm but just the coolest like
nerd dude I ever met in my life right
this other kid Andy he for some reason
thought that he wanted to convince
everybody that he was a gangster like I
don't [ __ ] know but I kid you [ __ ]
not I can still remember I can still
remember clear as day the first time I
ever saw him it was it was bad not my
dorm but my friend but my friend's dorm
and that was the dorm that I used to
kick it in a lot it was an older dorm
but it just had all my friends there
that phase it was during college yeah I
guess yeah he was I remember him because
his room was at the far end of the
dormitory and when he was walking up to
me he had a wife black bead he had a
black wife beater a wife black warranty
defect yes he had a black tank top
mm-hmm on you know the ones that you get
from fruit of the looms are really tight
one to your body like a wife beater yeah
yeah so those super tight ones and then
he was wearing these baggy basketball
shorts kind of had he was kind of
hunched over a little bit had these
little Asian spices here and he was like
kind of sagging and walking at the same
time and I thought it was like a joke I
was like who is this guy is he like
making a joke or something he's like who
sir and I'm like I'm gonna slap the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of you dude but
immediately because he was trying to act
all tough kind of mean mug people and
I'm like bro first of all he had like a
stutter right he had a stutter and like
a weird slight Lisp and I'm like who the
[ __ ] are you scaring right now man but
we're all college students here like
what would you even and he's like the
funniest thing about this was there's
this point where this dude named his
name was James and James is actually
from Diamond Bar this guy's a little
[ __ ] drug addict rich ass kid is that
as import exporting whatever that
[ __ ] means but just to the he was in
the country country club yeah so he
lives in the country big-ass house his
house was like a [ __ ] castle yeah
Valladares yes exactly that type of [ __ ]
like he had maids that raised him so but
he would the weird thing about James is
he was a kleptomaniac so he would steal
[ __ ] all the time it was like his
exciting thing like a buddy of mine told
me that he stole once stole like like a
snowboard just walked out with it like
he just loved stealing [ __ ] guys like
dead in the brain
long story short he steals a bunch of
hungry-man dinners from a food for less
what he was just stealing [ __ ] right I
didn't know but he just had a bunch he's
so basically what he did he just walked
into a food for listen you start dumping
into the cart and just walked out with
it and nobody stopped him but he would
steal [ __ ] all the time and I think he
was so dumb and it would look so
confident it looked like he already paid
for it that's he didn't look suspicious
cuz he was just that dumb so these
hungry man dinners he gave it to
everybody in the dorm
he was like yo just put it in your
freezer or whatever cool gave me a bunch
gave other people a bunch I gave it to
this guy and you Andy [ __ ] whatever
name is right different Andy yeah this
is no this is the the weird guy that was
acting like you met Doug so Andy comes
out and he asked he basically tells a
buddy Rishi and I was he goes yo man he
goes can I talk to you guys real quick
yo so uh you know I used to get in a lot
of trouble and [ __ ] like that and you
know I have like you know cops look
oh my god and I'm cringing just telling
this [ __ ] story
because I wanted to blow my brains out
listening to this guy and he was like I
can't have these hungry man dinners cuz
I might have to go to jail if I get
caught with this stuff and I'm like hey
number one
I'm going to slap the [ __ ] [ __ ] out
of you clearly he has never done a bad
thing in his life hungry man dinners
like he was acting as if a SWAT team was
gonna fly through the window and scream
for his hungry man dinners like what the
[ __ ] like guy shut the [ __ ] up and this
is these are there was so many people
like this in college and it used to make
me sick because I think at the time it
yeah we're all young we're trying to
figure out who we are
yeah right and arguably I probably did
the opposite like I try to hide who I
was because I didn't want people to
judge me I didn't want people to know
that I was a kid that grew up poor and
everything else like that of course
wanna we want to blend in yeah I just
wanted to blend in a little bit right
but you know my tendencies come out like
it is it is what it is it is Who I am
and when I got more comfortable which
was so weird because I was doing
stand-up at that time I just kind of
decided that you know what dude I'm just
gonna just be myself
yeah and then when I started being
myself I started feeling a lot better
but that's when like I I kind of had the
reputation of just literally saying
whatever was on my mind yeah because I
got sick of it College is where I really
got sick of it I was like these people
these people around me are so [ __ ]
fake just be your [ __ ] self like
literally it got to a point people are
like I need a bracelet that says what
would David do because even at a time
that W what would you just do they're
like where's the bracelet that says what
would David do cuz I punch something
yeah I mean at that time but it wasn't
that it was more like just just be
yourself just say whatever the [ __ ] you
want there's this other guy his name was
I think his name was Darren but this
dude was [ __ ] obnoxious like I so
crazy how you remember college like
these I remember these people because I
hated them like they I hate I don't
remember my roommate names my friend
really I remember all of them dude I
mean I remember who she they are but I
don't like I don't remember their names
I'm trying to remember my freshman year
my roommate she was a American American
lady mm-hmm and I remember American
would mean their ranking she was white
okay well I had two roommates one was uh
he's American she was super whitewashed
and then the other one was straight-up
like sorority girl my girl and I was I
was in a triplet room and you know I was
just being myself I'm like I have my you
know I love watching anime so I will
watch my anime I love my Korean food so
I hope my kimchi and my ramen my
whatever you know and one time I was
alone in the room and I was watching
anime having my kimchi and my instant
ramen and then this girl the white girl
my white roommate she comes in with her
friend and she comes in and gives me
like the most disgusting look of like
what just happened in this room what is
this smell and she's like oh what is
this smell and that was a shocking
moment for me because I grew up around
Asian so I never everybody does I smell
yeah I never ever thought that someone
would say that or even think of as like
a disgusting smell it's just kimchi
smell but she didn't grow up around
Asian she's super white and so she had
no idea what happened and on top of that
she's hearing like you know I was
watching bleach at that time and then
you know bleach they make a lot of like
screaming noises and she's not used to
that so she all cheer her and her friend
are like looking at each other and I'm
like I am Batgirl
yeah that you know the big typical geek
girl that why people judge so isn't that
weird though I was so shocked here's
here's the weird part now if you think
about it and how adays that would never
happen yeah a white person will walk
into your room and be like oh I love
kimchi can I get some of that do no
wrong isn't it crazy how much has
changed though because these and you
know we call them like school lunch box
moments right and what I mean by lunch
box lunch box moments it's like when we
were a kid and we had Asian food right
if we brought our Asian food to us go in
mind you like my school had a lot of
Asian kids but even then no matter what
even if we had a lot of Asian kids it
was still whatever however prevalent it
was the American sandwich the ham and
cheese sandwich whatever was the
standard with the white bread with the
white bread was by the
that's just delicious I don't I love
that she tomato peanut butter and jelly
sandwich with Wonder Bread
I did not understand that but I still
wanted it right there was that golden
stuff I don't know why I wanted it so
bad I hated it but I wanted it cuz I
also like you expressed how American you
were you know this podcast is brought to
you by fiber my friends if you have not
heard of fiber before what are you doing
with your life if you need freelance
talent that you need for personal
projects or maybe even a small business
or just something that you're doing for
fun like for me I use fiber for to find
illustrators for album art covers or
anything that I need for my small
businesses because there are a lot of
people out there that can help you get
you what you need and they offer a lot
of different services man and on top of
that let me just give you a quick list
of why fiber is super super easy to use
you can search by service deadline price
reviews and you'll know exactly what
you're paying for upfront no negotiating
needed and it's 24/7 customer service
sellers have worked with some of the
most influential brands in the world
finding talent for your project has
never been easier you can review seller
ratings a buyer feedback and select the
right floor you'll answer based on your
budget so it just basically makes it
pain free for you you don't have to go
by word of mouth you could actually see
actually see ratings and reviews I've
used it multiple times and every time
I've used them I've got exactly what I
needed
on the said time which by the way is not
an easy thing especially when you work
with certain freelance people who don't
follow these deadlines but every time I
have used Fiverr I've got the stuff on a
very timely manner and the communication
was very seamless so check out Fiverr
calm today and receive 10% off your
first order by using my code GB it's so
easy find all the digital services you
need in one place at fi ve are are.com
code GB again that's fiverr.com code GB
and so that definition of what being an
American was was literally based on
these school lunch foods and that's
where it kind of molds your idea of what
it is to be an American right and so I
remember when I was a kid too I used to
try to bring like a kimchi fried kimchi
Pokemon kimchi fried rice right and
the first person that stopped me wasn't
he one of the kids was my dad my dad was
I hate don't bring that at school I was
like why would he know huh I think it's
because he was just more mindful of it
because he knows how bad kimchi smells
to other people like his in the store
people are yeah what's that smell you
know and then was kimchi it's like hey
don't bring them to school yeah but for
me I was like I'm gonna bring the school
right - I don't do it like people thinks
people are gonna think it smells how old
were you mmm I can I can remember what
the kitchen looked like and everything
else and the moment that my dad said it
and what even what the Pokemon looked
like that day but I can't remember how
old I was but it was it was definitely
when I went to Isabel Jackson the son
anxious elementary school because I
remembered that Pokemon because it was
in a ziploc Tupperware uh-huh and inside
it was the first time my mom put have
button mushrooms in it and that's the
first time about mushrooms and the
kimchi poking about I remember that
thank you fried rice
yeah keeps you fried rice so but my dad
told me not to bring it because it was
smelling the kid other kids would make
fun so what happened at school
did you microwave it is there a
microwave back no no no no and you just
eat a cold because I can't remember it
was not good when I bring it to school
as I why is it cold I don't like this
and then yeah I would have friends would
be like looking at me and I'm like I
want Lunchables yeah and it's in that
moment - is so weird because I mean I'm
pretty sure that girl was you know she
didn't mean any harm when she was
looking at you eating your food but it
is a weird smell I mean let's just be
real yeah it's not a good smell
yeah it's fermented is fermented fish
and shrimp that's trash that's fermented
by the moon just means like you're
rotting it in it smells pretty bad it
does I get it you know yeah I just
sitting you know I mean middle school
and high school I grew up around a lot
of Asian so it was I was customed to
like it's fine to just eat it all so
it's my first time I'm his freshman year
in college I don't know if she I don't
know anything about sharing rooms with
like random people and I'm sure she
didn't mean it that way too but I'm
pretty sure it was pretty shocking I
mean if I smell fish sauce door like I'm
sure I would have said the same thing
yeah I mean it's pretty shocking too
it's just kind of like with the one
thing that we won't that a lot of kids
won't get now is that reaction right now
I think because food has opened up so
much to a lot of people in America
because of social media because of
digital digital television shows they
know what these foods aren't they know
what these smells are because now it's
gonna be yeah that smells but I wonder
what that is yeah and that's a positive
change has happened a lot and I think
sometimes people get people are a little
bit against me when I talk about food in
this sense because sometimes when
especially in media when they you know
say like why people they they think they
or they feel like they're taking our
food and taking make getting credit for
it which kind of sucks but the upside to
that is that now that these foods and
these cultures are being introduced into
a culture that used to not understand
and be disgusted by it now they're a lot
more open and they're willing to learn
yeah right now it's just a matter of
like how respectful are they of you know
taking part in the culture but not
taking credit for it exactly
that's the hard part yeah and you know
if I look back I wish this generation
happened during our kids our kids our
years when we were a kid because like I
could have appreciated my families my
grandma's food a lot more it's hard
because back then I'll be like I'm
grandma or you know you don't parents
with parents I would make the food to be
like I know we don't want this because
we're being judged by it but it's such
good food and I remember I was just
always kind of like shy or like trying
to hide my food because it would smell
first of all and it would not be the
popular food I just want to eat you know
peanut butter and jelly with everyone
else so I would weird how like you're a
cultural how American quote-unquote you
are can be even identified by the food
that you put in your [ __ ] mouth it's
so it's like as an adult when I look at
that it's like why like why is that so
important but when you're a kid you just
want to fit in it's like these other
kids when they come to school they just
eat this sandwich right and even VIN
still talked about a time where he Vince
is the guy that shoots a lot of my
videos you know back in the day when I
was doing a lot of food content but
Vince told the story to me a while ago
where he I forgot what it was it was
like sushi or something that he brought
to school oh and he exchanged it he
exchanged it yeah but people were
weirded out by sushi but if you look at
it now everybody wants sushi they look
at sushi like it's
it's filet mignon you know like you
bring sushi to school now they're like
let me get something fancy stuff yeah
and it's it's weird watching the
evolution of food and peeping people I
love it I love that people are
appreciating now and like people are
understanding or they want to understand
of like you know Asian food of it like
me bringing kimchi it to work now is not
a weird thing it's just like you know it
smells so I'll make sure you know to be
mindful about it but they're not gonna
be disgusted by it
yeah and that's that's the cool thing to
wear I think even though like during
these times it's kind of its kind of
rough because you see like certain areas
are still the way that it is like you
bring a bottle of kimchi they'll make
fun of you right like maybe like the
Midwest or some [ __ ] like that right
they're still you know big pockets nice
country you know we're very blessed to
be in California right but the cool
thing is that in California from what
we've seen it's there's a progression
now right it's like that definition of
what it is to be a quote-unquote
American has changed a lot in California
right because now you're American this
isn't necessarily based on like the
color of your skin or what food you eat
it's more like how much you appreciate
this country and how you behave because
now to be culturally inclusive is
becoming more American I feel anyways in
a city like LA yeah it's interesting cuz
it is definitely more inclusive but also
very you got to be very sensitive you
got extra sensitive of like you're gonna
say hi you're gonna say things I think
there definitely needs to be a balance
of that because sometimes I think people
are just overly sensitive but it's a
good progress it's swinging back and
forth like some you know there were
times where people are a little too
crass like you know when we look at
stand up back in the day even uh Eddie
Murphy talked about this where Eddie
Murphy said that he was embarrassed like
when he looks back at some of his
material that he used to talk about
specifically when he came to the gay
community calling them [ __ ] you know
and kind of making these jokes in the
expense of making fun of them without
any nuance you know even Eddie Murphy
says this he goes like yeah I look back
then I kind of regret that like you know
like he wasn't making an observation
about gay culture in the way that he
doesn't know it he was making fun of it
and they were a butt of a joke
you know
and it was it was more like [ __ ] in a
negative way you know which of course it
could be it always probably always
interpreted in a negative way yeah but I
can kind of grasp what I'm saying is
that that there's a generational gap so
before people were really extreme and
now we swung to the other side of the
pendulum where it's like you can't say
anything and I get really sad because I
watched recently I saw on Netflix the
Dave Chappelle Mark Twain Award mm-hmm
and watching that was something that
kind of makes me want to go back into
doing stand-up again because a lot of a
lot of comedians are the ones that I
like anyways that say things maybe now I
don't want to say important but can make
a joke out of anything right in that
comedy realm is starting to disappear
because they're so scared to say
anything because they might offend
somebody yeah comedy is going to be
offensive you're supposed to say things
that you know that you either think it's
just about how you do it yeah like
there's a sacred space in comedy where I
truly feel that people should be able to
work out their material and if you don't
like it you have an option to not listen
or just to leave simple as that but if
80% of the crowds laughing and there's
20 and there's like that 20% or maybe
even 5% and like that's offensive then
guess what that comedians actually doing
their job you know and it's also you're
not yeah back in the days like you would
you know you would apply to go and watch
them like you are the one who went there
to watch a comedy show but now it's like
anyone could attend yeah like you could
totally make something that's not true
make it into something that's very
offensive and it will upload a video and
and and the thing about that too is like
I'm not saying that you're not allowed
to be if it you are a hundred thousand
percent allowed to be offended but it's
should allowed them to still perform
their jokes because you're allowed to be
offended they should still be allowed to
perform their jokes that's really
challenging
it's a weird balance like III understand
too because I had to look back at this
guy name I did a podcast about it as
listening Shane Gillis so Shane Gillis
had a podcast and he was talking about
how you know he was just you know just
saying really like racially insensitive
tough stuff towards Asian people when
people ask me is like don't you wish he
was kin
the site I don't think Shane Gillis's
career should be cancelled because he
said like highly offensive [ __ ] you know
because as a comic I don't know whether
it's because I'm more human around more
comic I'm like that's a crappy set I
guess you know like just whatever cuz he
in his defense he was saying that those
were jokes but when I was listening to
him talk about Asian people in Asian
culture it didn't sound like a joke it
just sounded like he was observing how
disgusted he was of Asian people so I
was like if that's that's not a joke
like there's no nuance to it like you're
not pulling a stand-up set you're not
making a joke and I listened to that
podcast too full of it and I was like no
there was no setup to it there was no
joke after it it was just him and his
buddy or his brother talking about how
disgusting Asian people are I was like
if there was a joke in it I definitely
would've gave it a pass but I did but
when you when people ask me like should
Shang Gilles have been canceled I say no
because he'll rework his [ __ ] he won't
do that again and then he'll make some
other material I'm pretty sure he's
[ __ ] funny because Shane Gilles
actually got into SNL he was an STD
did he have a comeback about how he
approached the comic so I saw this
interview of him afterwards and he felt
that he was like misrepresented or or
whatever which I don't think he was
misrepresented I think that the sad part
is is that if in fact it was calm I
don't think he should get cancelled over
those type of things
I think cancelling somebody because you
don't find his jokes funny is weird yeah
I had the right to be offended as a
criticize but not cancel like it's not
the end of the world it's just you got
to learn from it
yeah they accept it and learn it's hard
though bugs because people get excited
that they can cancel somebody's career
over them that's the thing right now is
that I think that's what people are so
afraid of like they're always afraid
yeah that it's so much easier to ruin
someone's reputation no well here's the
thing too it's like I I read this quote
somebody said that just because it was
like just because you don't find it
funny it doesn't mean that it isn't or
it wasn't something like but it was more
like it was way more profound I'm sorry
it was like just because you find it
offensive it doesn't mean that it's not
funny and that's facts just cuz you
specific there's a lot of people in
stand-up comedy there's in film that I
find their [ __ ] trash but just because I
think it's
trash doesn't mean that it is that's
just my singular opinion of what it is
but it's those people who can't really
say out loud in front of people they're
the one who are the loudest online oh
for sure yeah so it's and those are the
majority of the people unfortunately
there are the most active people out
there rather than people who are the
good people don't really say much you
know yeah so I think that's the it's
like there's a ups and downs to it you
know you could be more exposed but you
could also the more exposed you are the
more hates you could comes along with
yeah we were talking about Tara Stiles
well we went to a random tangent I know
you went to a comedy section I'm like
that's not my field yeah
but you know Pepe just to go back I love
Pepe she loves you real and there's his
father you really love or y'all you you
you were you know you're you changed
your perspective of him because of the
new season so there's this girl that
came on by the way if I ever get to meet
this girl I want her on this podcast if
I ever get to meet her I wanna I want to
have a handshake okay okay maybe a hug
is this jermeir hug girl we German
Russian German well I think she's German
uh death nicly but she moved to Russia
so she's she's German descent she's
Russian in the sense of rates in Russia
yeah yeah raised in Russia so but she
went to Japan after high school and stay
there for about six years growing up she
wanted to go to university over there
especially University I don't know if it
was fashion or something where I believe
it was her fashion fashion yeah and then
that was she thought that was her
passion and then it actually developed
to something else where she's modeling
there and trying to become a spurring
aspiring actress and she is the most
cute adorable charismatic mature nice
amazing lady ever and the reason why she
doesn't like video if you guys watch
this season it's because of how y'all
and Vivi their relationship starts to
develop and this is a the reason why I
like this show what they're going
through isn't like real world [ __ ]
in terms of real
the reality TV show oh no this is it's
like stuff that every one of us has gone
through and we're seeing it unwrapped
into like other people's personal
relationships because it's not highly
exaggerated it just is what it is
so REO and vivvy are in this weird
situation right so you know like when
you watch somebody and you could tell
like there's heart eyes like there for
the moment there was his moment on the
show where Vivi just literally but punt
but moved him with her but to they were
arguing about who's gonna wash the
dishes and I'm like those two are gonna
[ __ ] eventually that's the first thing I
thought really I was like I wish I was
more like damn that girl's cute I was
like that's um that's a major flirting
right oh yeah absolutely I love that
because the first thing I thought was
Merrill used to do that with me
and now she does farts in front of me
24/7 hey we fart each other yeah dude
let me tell you something this girl
she's been to we make music out of fire
this one this is how we communicate time
this woman has been farting like a
shipping boat I'm just shocked about how
much you fart now food that you could
give me I eat a lot of cheese thanks to
you well I don't want to eat a lot of
cheese yeah we have pizza last night and
I was farting away the only cheese that
we have in this house I usually eat like
those cheese wheels for snacks that's
why you fart all the time I got a reply
scream yes it's the same communique same
language a farts don't smell that just
loud as [ __ ] I know yours on the other
hand they baby them to have a tinge of
an odor
I'd be known that not all the time I
squeal and say not all the time not all
the time but what they do you do warn me
and it's too late by then
yeah I could tell by the heat that comes
out of my ass if it's hot it's gonna
smell if it's nice and cool no smell
that's so gross if I wonder why I don't
know and you go to the bathroom really
well yeah anyway Vivi and yo did BB BB
vvvvv sorry I think the weird part too
is like we were there was a point on the
show where she and I were having
differences not not like me and Mariel
about our opinion of real oh yeah
I was told I mean honestly I'm pretty
biased about it because I'm feeling for
Vivi like how hurtful she is or well it
spoilers earlier anyway just how the
pain she's going through I could totally
sympathize with her yeah in a way I
could sympathize with Yura but not
really like I'm just like my heart is
all on baby yeah I mean well because in
the show REO and her have this very
often on relationship but the flirting
that they have is really big it's it's
finally apparent he's very
straightforward derivational which by
the way was very refreshing to see a
woman I'm not to be like this is how I
feel about you and she's so cute the way
she approaches thing and it's so it's
such a late I don't know it's like it's
very responsible she's not forcing
herself she's not trying to be someone
else she's not trying to be creepy like
you know obviously I'm describing
someone else she's just everything like
her her laugh her approach the way she
like is this Korean drama what am i
watching well I am she's she's being
ridiculous right now I mean that's why
there was a point where so essentially
what happened was Vivi confronts deal
about their relationship and she wants
them to solidify what they have you know
I mean like make it official right yeah
cuz he's flirting like DTF like let's
define the relationship Oh DTR define
the relationship right you know Donna
[ __ ] no it's in tyfa okay yeah but they
wanted to find the relationship and but
he always very wishy-washy which I
understand is very it's kind of
obnoxious right it's like you had been
flirting you have been doing business
and that but his reasoning for not
wanting to commit to her is the fact
that she's an actress and she's gonna
move to LA he doesn't like long-distance
relationships which for me I felt was a
cop-out right that that wasn't the case
that might be a slight reason why you
don't want to but that's just the thing
that he's holding on to to say like I'm
not ready to commit yeah right yeah and
for her I think because she's so in love
yeah she's like oh well I never said
that I was going to leave out right yeah
but she could have really read between
the lines of like he's actually not that
committed to me I think she could be
I told understand why she couldn't read
between the lines because he responded
to her by flirting back
yeah but flirting doesn't mean [ __ ]
though like for her that's all she sees
she has a filter well she's in love with
him
exactly so she wants to make sure like
any opportunity where she could catch
him she will take it you know so even at
the end when they decided that hey it's
not gonna happen she went all out and
that was an amazing moment yeah I mean
she was so at this point like if you
guys haven't seen it it's not listening
here but there was girls gonna leave the
house and then she just had this kdrama
like moment where she almost was kissing
him to convince him to stay it was like
she had that conviction she literally
grabbed his face and kissed him in the
most non-japanese way possible which was
very very American kissing oh it was
very romantic it was very romantic but
you could even tell like even the way he
was kissing her back he was unsure but
he didn't he didn't back off well that's
the thing so she's like there's that
even 1% chance of it and so you know
spoiler alert again when he boiler it
spoil I can't spoil it earlier though
after he leaves
they still communicate and what Vivi has
said is that she wanted to stop talking
to him but as soon as she did that go
would text her even more she gets the
weird game of cat-and-mouse like it's
it's it's just he just wanted both he's
like I love our chemistry and I won't
ask you ball and I like basketball I
want to keep both but I don't want to
commit yeah you can't have your cake and
eat you too guy doesn't work that way
especially because she's more committed
to him than she is mm-hmm he is there
I'm not really hurt to see like what
what the pain she was going through
that's why I can't sympathize with you
it's just like you're going back and
forth you said that cannot happen yeah
you're texting her so often and you're
saying let's give it a lot of guys do
that [ __ ] though bastard it's not even
guys like girls that too a lot like
people people always want what they
can't have
right and the moment starts to slip away
they start to reach out a little more
but that's why even like when when
people give advice about how to get
guys are how to get women they teach you
about not being too readily available
yeah
it's about kind of playing that fine
balance in life you can have me but
let's just you know we'll see about
Korean you call that why but that's the
fun part right because there's a game
even for me I've never liked a girl who
has outright like me I like chasing and
I like a little bit of you know give you
know back yeah it's fun
trust me you didn't look at too much I
was gonna leave I should have left I
should have left this woman just back
and forth all the time all the time I'm
just natural you too busy trying to date
other people I uh I know I told for God
about that I don't even remember their
names
I don't remember their names either but
I remember that they went mountain
biking a lot and then issues some
annoying thing she would mention about
the other guys accolades to me like oh
babe mountain bike oh they do this and
I'm like and I literally got sick of it
and I told her like I don't like this
like I don't like being transparent be
like hey we're dating other people so
I'm telling you who I date it yeah but
you were doing in a way of you saying
things that they do versus what I do
like I didn't like and I was like either
you like me or you do whatever you still
liked me
yeah I said I lady I like sit down I was
like David so don't play no games a
woman and I said that when I put a cigar
in my mouth I went it was it was a
bubble pipe Davis oh don't play no games
like that you like you more chatter Bowl
started coming out and then you got high
oh yes I got high from the ball yeah but
you you I it so weird when I I watched
how you guys were just like fawning over
this guy which I got he's very charming
and charismatic but this is it's not
really yeah but it's switched right when
you saw a little thing that you thought
you didn't really agree with have
suddenly he's the enemy he was you just
it's just it's one of those like I knew
it
he can't be perfect but he was never you
know I
he's not a bad person no you know
he's he's actually fairly young he's
trying to pursue his dream which I think
it was a very good decision that he made
that call it's just I wish he committed
after he left and said he wanted to
going back and forth back and forth he
didn't want to be in front of a camera
doing that it's a little irresponsible
on his part in terms of like him kind of
not committing to what he said he was
going to do but I was also disappointed
to be b2 it's like you know you're
letting this guy control your emotions
totally well you say it's your call do
you want this or not yeah
no it's your call it's like you it's
your call and I think that was the one
time like Vivi she kind of disappointed
me I'm like you have every power right
now to take this power in your hands and
say hey you told me what you wanted that
I really sweat she could have made out
with him and when he called back you
don't pick up the [ __ ] phone Vivi but
she was so in love with him she had to
pick up the phone I was like you just
gave you just showed your whole hand to
this dude yeah yeah but that's the
Korean trauma part that I love and then
you think it's over and then you go and
there is a chance if you guys watch the
scene where they made out it was the
most dramatic kdrama thing I've ever
even the lines were so beautiful that's
the thing the freight like [ __ ] no talks
very well like he's very good at saying
things and you know like to learn a
lesson and Vivi just has always have
faced drama lines and so good I'm like
how did you think about her jab her
Japanese is [ __ ] amazing like
Japanese friends text me saying how
amazing her Japanese is like I don't
even speak Japanese like that but just
listening to her I'm like it's her
Japanese that damn good because there's
a certain level of when you guys yeah
like oh my god relax
if you guys don't speak a second
language there's levels to this [ __ ]
right so like my Korean level is like
that is like a four-year-old right so I
can communicate what I need to
communicate I can it's more than four
okay but it's a grandma no it's like an
old lady's an old lady but I can
communicate decently well right like if
I went to Korea I'd be fine
I might get made fun of but I was
showing on Chinese and I'll be
I'm Taiwanese and they'll be like your
dreams pretty damn good being a
Taiwanese do but and there's this other
level when they start to speak about
inter like the way she and I are
speaking English right now where I can
elaborate what I'm saying with just a
large of an ocular that's the level that
Vivi's at oh yeah it's like she could
speak Japanese like I can speak English
oh absolutely just so crazy yeah it it
blows my mind and she does as so well
she articulates her line so well that's
why I think she's so maturely
compared to other kids yeah I just know
I'm thinking like that they're kids
but other roommates that she has like
she could speak so well give it vice so
well and it's not even her first time it
was the way she would give advice to
when she was giving advice I'm like
that's how I talk like that's not it
took me till I'm [ __ ] 32 less like
the help well the 24-year old talking
like right now because people usually
her age that say that they're mature and
they try to give people advice it's not
like that now it's very immature in his
dump because I was that age I thought I
was smart but she's the only person I
know at the age of 24 that I feel knows
what she's talking about
and it might be because she made the big
move at 18 to move to another country
and grow up yeah so she's experienced
these things of having to grow up these
interpersonal relationships from working
being in school into a completely
foreign area where she's specially the
culture difference between Russia and oh
she even said - I think she said that uh
I forgot somebody said something to her
in German and she says she said she
speaks Japanese better than she says
German now oh really yeah which is
amazing yeah that's all she said she's
so damn cute she is so cute the first
thing that Muriel said when she said she
goes look at that body
girls are so fly girls check out other
girls more than twice a girl girl oh you
have no idea how much we check out each
other's body that's so funny
yeah she's super cute she got an amazing
body but most of all amazing personality
there's one girl on the show that I
really really just it's hard to like is
his girl Hannah Hana Hana is so hard to
like and hers is up and down like ah
she's getting better and then it was so
weird because Hana on the show also had
a huge crush on on the show and she
would just be sobbing crying her eyes
out because he always giving more
attention to Phoebe
number one little child you guys didn't
even have a relationship so what are you
crying about
number two she was like upset that Vivi
was taking over or whatever but Vivi was
taking an initiative you didn't you kind
of stood back and you expected things to
just happen and then you got upset and
you were crying about something that you
didn't take the initiative to change you
just expected him to fall in love with
you it's like wow you never had a
relationship yeah I said just cuz you're
around it doesn't and then her friends
were so [ __ ] dumb you know what I
think though I mean
vivy obviously grew up a lot of life
experiences a lot of life experience I'm
sure she encountered a lot of people
growing up not only in Europe but also
in Japan whereas Hana she grew up in a
bubble she also plays sports she's a
professional wrestler and I'm sure she
grew up with certain people for a really
long time and she's living in that
bubble so she doesn't know what's
outside of that and I'm sure she didn't
have that social experience that maybe
would have had I think the annoying
thing was that her friends too were just
as inexperienced but they're trying to
give her life advice it was like there
was this part in the show this was the
dumbest thing I've ever heard my life it
was like oh if you bring your class
closer to him and he doesn't push it
away that means that he likes you it's
like are you [ __ ] three years old all
three of you grown-ass women you know
what they say sports players they are a
lot more innocent than because they
focus on their sport yeah they're just
they're just more pure and innocent and
on the show I I was I wanted to rip my
teeth out watching her scootch over her
little glass to see if he would push it
away and she looks so [ __ ] desperate
it's like yeah [ __ ] get your [ __ ]
together man and we look like part two
the whole season for her to realize okay
I have no chance with him he doesn't
like you right and so you're just like
scooting over her wine glass or her
glass over to see if he for some reason
and they remind me of like I forgot on
it was in the Hawaii season where they
told Yusuke like oh wear this t-shirt it
shows your March mature girls will like
that told you that that your [ __ ]
t-shirt is the reason that why this
girl's gonna like you [ __ ] says this you
you're taking advice for people who
don't know what the [ __ ] they're talking
about you know they're I mean there are
the people that they're serving
by so that's all you learn right that's
exactly the point is that you're
surrounded by certain people that has
limited experience so that's all you're
gonna know so she's in that wrestling
world with those friends that's all they
know like her obnoxious behavior that
she has is that when she has to talk
about something serious or be real about
stuff she starts giggling uncontrollably
nobody so it's like how is anybody
supposed to take you serious and then
you get upset for people not taking you
serious yeah and it's weird too because
on that end she's also a type of person
that what I've seen on the show and the
reason why I'm saying this I'm
committing to this this concept and who
this person is is because from my
personal experience from certain people
from terrorist house the show does a
good job of representing all these
people so oh god she has this with this
weird thing of kind of like putting
herself above people in terms of her
opinion when she has very little life
experience and she's like clearly a big
[ __ ] herself right so she has this
thing of like oh I can save why the wine
this is how I feel and she's very
adamant about her position which is okay
I think that's fine but it's like turn
the tables around look at the flaws of
yourself like you can't be in this like
put yourself up on a pedestal when
you're you're arguably beneath these
other people I wonder is because her
profession she's just she's a really
good performer you obviously like she's
up there and that's her entire life I
mean she didn't have a relationship I
think she her family is in that industry
too so that's all she knows and she's
the best so who's gonna be out there
telling her that she's lower than any
yeah yeah I mean she's like on the forex
spectrum of like it's like hyper
emotional like crying and sobbing and
then it's on the other end of just like
completely unaffected like how other
people are like she had this one when
they became really good friends later
Amica Amica yeah but literally she's
like outing her out in front of the guy
that she likes or has a crush on right
and she goes well why can't I say this
stuff about you to him in front of him
when that's how you actually feel it's
like okay [ __ ] so when we tell you
things in confidence you're just gonna
go ahead and blab it to somebody right
in front them you dumbass it's like one
of those things it's like oh it's like
oh it's cool isn't it it's like cool
also like it's cuz she has an experience
there herself so she's only thinking
about the scenario be like what's wrong
with that
you know I mean it's like people she
would hate it if somebody did that to
her though
it's like a hard life but she doesn't
know because she never experienced yeah
so it's like one of those like where
people don't haven't gone into a
relationship and then they have all
these like scenarios and imagination
it's like I don't understand why are you
crying and still be with him yeah but
I'm saying like for her it's like if you
don't have that experience how dare you
have such a harsh it like opinion about
that stuff humans have opinions yeah
which is perfectly fine but it's like
kind of how she went about it that was
her yeah she is she just basically needs
more life experience that was that was a
first taste of her that I was like I
don't like you it's like you can't yeah
it's scary like you don't you don't just
go out and out somebody out like that
and then you're supposed to be you're
friends with and then also you start
playing oh don't you like this person in
front of the guy it's like why don't you
just [ __ ] on her chances I think that's
why I think it's a very good experience
for her to be oh she needs that show for
sure because her once again her
reasoning for that for saying that stuff
is like well it's true you do feel that
way right it's like cool if that's the
case too and there's no new ones to
relationships or conversations and we're
not going to consider other people's
feelings we can say whatever it's like
which is not Japanese at all
yeah even where did the [ __ ] did you get
the not happening well it's just not
polite at all now any type of sense it's
like cool it's like what if she did that
to you like you like you know and then
as you guys are having dinner she goes
hey didn't you say this about yo
yesterday about you think his dick is
gonna be really nice or some [ __ ] like
that oh right and then it's like why
would you yeah well it's sure right that
is what you said there's a lot of things
that are true that we just don't say
like you jackass like what's wrong with
you but then she's like that type of
person but that she still has a hot
that's why her character is so weird
like I'm like who are you
it's very interesting this season it's
just a lot of different characters and
remember when Vivi and Neil were
flirting and then over the stairs she's
just like a little [ __ ] pervert
Donna's peeking over staring at them
like a creep it's like [ __ ] it shows
just how she was very innocent very pure
I would say yeah very innocent and pure
she's a she's a kid and you know it's
like what the hell were you thinking man
like what were you doing I shamed that's
why it's a very good idea for your kids
or people to have experience outside of
your bubble Oh
traveling is the biggest thing for
people moving abroad living abroad
living with people that you know that
you don't really know that's why
colleges for sure for me if when I have
a when we have kids I even if the
college isn't their life they don't want
to I want them to at least go to college
for at least a year that I want them to
experience dorm experience being in a
situation where you're forced to live
with other people who have different
life experiences you and just kind of
being in that weird it's a weird
situation like now whenever in your life
are you gonna go to a new place a new
school new people forced to live with
these people who live different you have
different cleanliness standards right
eat different foods it's it's it's a
really huge growing experience even if
our kids is like hey I don't think I'm
gonna use college it's like cool I hope
I still I still want you I had a great
experience like I went to I went to so
many different schools in college that I
think it was a lot of work and really
hard but at the same time was very
rewarding just the amount of experience
that I got from it yeah and I agree to
like even with my dad kind of like he
kind of forced me to go to Riverside I'm
glad I got to live that dorm experience
because if not like first of all I
wouldn't have that story about weird
Andy and the other there's another story
about this other guy named Andrew Jiang
this other guy named Darren I got weird
stories from these people will tell it
will tell it another time but it was a
huge growing experience because I got to
learn what it was like to live with
people that you just don't agree with
one time to this this other Japanese kid
that I live with I almost [ __ ] killed
this guy because he was so [ __ ]
disgusting like he would never clean his
dishes and it's so weird we talked about
because when there are kids or is he
from Japan he's a Japanese American Oh
like like third floor Japanese kids they
grow up what learning how to clean and
take care of them I found out why he was
like that though and this was actually
my first lesson of like oh you really
are a product of your environment
his mom sweetest lady ever shoes she
worked at the post office post office
lady took him to press so his father
passed away when he was really young huh
he's actually not a bad dude it's just
because he was a little pampered little
[ __ ] growing up because his mom I think
because his dad passed away when he was
younger and you know his mom is doing
double work but for me at the time all I
thought was like how dare
you be like this when your mom is doing
so much work for you to make sure that
you have his life but his mom pampered
him a lot so I never had to make his own
food never had to clean up after himself
and I found this out when we when I
spent the night at his place
I knew he lived in Torrance and then we
were kicking it and he was like oh won't
you come over to sleep at my spot in
Torrance you know and just to get out of
La yeah crash at his place spent the
night there and I was like his mom
literally it's just one step away from
wiping his ass at the age of like 1918
and so I was like that's the way that's
why he is the way that he is that's
interesting cuz I mean I I have to admit
like I've been well pampered to like I
have my grandma doing everything for me
but when I got into college like I took
care of myself so well I mean Tillis day
like I am very yeah he didn't claim he
long story short he didn't clean up any
of his dishes he was super sloppy and
messy and wouldn't take responsibility
for the stuff that he was doing and it
got to the point where you know I'm I'm
I wasn't as straightforward as I am now
but I was pretty straightforward in the
sense of like hey bro can you like clean
your dishes today
yeah did he have any siblings no only
child and I was like you know can you
clean your dishes and I asked them
multiple times I forgot how many times
out I don't remember the specifics but
I'm gonna have my kids help me out for
sure yeah I think it's a good lie that's
what I liked about Japanese culture like
even when you saw baby Hana Hana uh-huh
well she's a wrestler right like these
people are performers but it's still to
clean the gym clean it teaches you
community like this is a space that you
use so you should respect this I [ __ ]
love that I also like in Japanese
culture and Japanese grade school where
you were there is no janitor the kids
are the ones that needs a place because
this is a place that you use they
sometimes make their own food too that's
awesome because also teaches respect the
place because it's like if you clean it
up you for sure won't be putting gum
everywhere because you're gonna be the
person has to speak exactly you work for
that cleanness so you make sure that you
take care of that space yeah and it's so
interesting because when I was a kid I
always I remember this like I would I
would ask my grandma but I can't help
you wash the dishes or it can I help you
cook but she always said no
but I was always the one who would be
like I want to do it I want to do it but
I never got the chance to because she
would be like no no it's just too much
work
yeah it's too much work to teaching them
for me just do it yeah yeah
but regardless like I still I think so I
think in my opinion like from what I've
experienced like living with so many
different roommates like I was very
concerned
I consider it and make sure that you
know my stuff wouldn't get in the way
for them like I remember when I moved to
Berkeley and got a new roommate in a
freaking tiny ass room she's like oh
I'll bring the vacuum it's like okay
I'll clean my section Oh like she
brought the vacuum and I clean our room
it's like let's just make the deal like
I'll make sure it's clean you just bring
the vacuum so like I always made sure
that our place was clean and you know
she was very respectful of my section I
was very respectful her section is so
like we wouldn't cross each other oh man
let me tell you about respect I had this
roommate named Daniel wool I grew up
with him in Sacramento and everything -
he lived in my neighborhood this dude
was so [ __ ] filthy but so respectful
he was so [ __ ] filthy and respectful
I mean like like we split our dorm room
right half half yeah he had his bunk I
had my bunk on the other side
he was so [ __ ] disgusting I would
only vacuum my side but it was my side
was so clean you could see a color
difference from his carpet to mine but
there was a perfect line and his stuff
never went over to my side that's how
respectful he was [ __ ] filthy see I
did both I clean vacuumed her section in
my section she
I hope they show us no she was very
clean - she was messy but miss I was
more clean I guess all right no she is
she was more or less like messy but her
son would never come over to mine but
when I need to vacuum she will always be
very respectful and like clean up so
that are you lean it yeah well let's
just
this is roommate low it's just how we
grew up I guess yeah I don't know man
but definitely college is one of those
experience that I I do want our kids to
experience eventually yeah just just
it's a unique experience that you'll
never so hopefully by then it's still
around like I mean after the whole
goodbye then college won't be so [ __ ]
expensive man or this whole kovat thing
I don't know how our lifestyle is gonna
change they're gonna find a vaccine and
then our lives will go back to same it
might be a seasonal thing though like
seasonal Kobe beef or they're saying
it's like the flu sorry we have to be
pretty serious about getting those
vaccinations if not if you don't want to
get that vaccine that your public died
so deal with it then
well guys this wraps up this episode of
the genius brain podcast you can find
Mariel at on instagram at Mariel
underscore underscore song interesting
talking about Tara's house and a lot of
a bunch of other [ __ ] actually yeah yeah
so we will see you guys next time
remember every Thursday and Sundays as a
genius brain podcast and yeah man
well [ __ ] talk to you then stay cool
stay sexy and be cute guys I love you
[ __ ]
[Music]